hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in rhetoric Book 2 one of the emotions
that Aristotle analyzes is that which we
translate as calmness or mildness proud
taste and this is a lack or quieting the
opposite of anger and in the course of
his discussion of calmness there is a
short paragraph which lists off a number
of different circumstances in which
people tend to be Palmer or milder this
isn't like Aristotle making
Universal claims that anybody who's in
these conditions will never feel any
anger whatsoever but these are some
generalizations and so he begins this by
telling us that people are mild or
exhibit mild this feel less angry or not
angry at all who are in circumstances
that are opposed to getting angry and we
should talk a little bit about the
terminology being used here it's a
little bit difficult to translate so
echoantes holding themselves in a
situation or finding themselves within a
condition or situation and then anantios
this is a anantia is opposites calmness
and anger are actually opposites
Aristotle says we can figure out what
makes people calm by looking at what
makes people angry and then
extrapolating from that to their
opposites here it's being used as an
adverb so people who are in situations
that are opposed to or that create
opposition to what to getting angry to
organza style this is a verb coming from
the actual noun describing the the
emotion Oregon and Oregon means to get
oneself angry to get riled up right so
we can look at a number of different
common situations and say in these
situations there could be some people
who have anger problems and they're
going to be angry no matter what but
people tend on the whole to not get
angry in these situations and what are
they you notice that there's a whole
bunch of n this N means in or uh in in
some cases at and so
there's a number of Greek terms some of
which are very easy to translate some of
which are a little bit tricky like the
very first one and pidia
Heist is a child right and paideia can
describe the kind of things that
children do so child child likeness
childishness
but it's often translated as play which
children engage in but so do adults you
know for example when we're playing
board games or video games or a nice
translation of this
at sport when we're engaging in physical
activity perhaps you know playing a
pickup game a basketball or soccer or
baseball or pick whatever else you you
want even just throwing a ball back and
forth could be paidia games like tag or
hide and seek or ghost in the graveyard
a popular one here in the Midwest in my
childhood these are all examples of idea
so you know people can get quite serious
about sports especially if they're
putting money or prestige on the line or
even just about games think about how
angry Gamers can get but if you're if
you're treating it as an actual game not
as serious activity where you got a
jockey with other people you are in a
state where you're less likely to become
angry in any serious way you might get
angry because you roll the dice and you
get a seven instead of a ten that you
needed but in general those who are at
play are going to be calm the next one
that he says
in laughter and this is quite
interesting right because he's using a
term that we could translate some other
terms a little bit earlier in the
section on anger as referring to
laughter right but what's really going
on here is a kind of innocent laughter
that's not provoking
um Rancor or problems a little bit
earlier in the section on anger he says
as to the objects of anger people are
angry with those who ridicule Mock and
scoff at them and the word for ridicule
is
katigalosi the galosi there it refers
refers to laughter but it's a different
kind of laughter it's like laughter at
somebody else's expense so if we can
laugh at ourselves and we can laugh at
the circumstances that we're in we're
less likely to be angry we were more
likely to be calm but if the laughter is
directed against somebody look at that
silly idiot over there
well that person's liable to get angry
because they're being laughed at not
laughed with
the third one and herote
um this could be translated as it is in
fact by some at a feast but I think that
we have to be a little bit careful in
how we think about this we typically
associate feasts with eating right and
that is indeed part of a feast but the
word that this is coming from means
something like at a festival or a
holiday something that is publicly
acknowledged as a time for celebration
and eating and drinking will be part of
that but it is not necessarily the sole
purpose of it of course if you're going
to something like a strawberry festival
or a Garlic Festival eating and eating
that particular food is Central but this
means any sort of occasion so it could
be something like a birthday it could be
something like a wedding it could even
be something I suppose like a funeral
all right that's a ceremonial occasion
the next one and Maria
um in prosperity it's a good way of
translating in a good condition of Life
the EU means well or good and uh emeria
you're sort of following that up so when
we are doing well
um that's you know a condition in which
we're less likely to get angry perhaps
because we don't feel the need to worry
or uh
scrimp and save or be in competition
with other people and then the the next
two are kind of like this as well we
could see them as all representing the
same matter but from different aspects
now that's coming from a word orthos
which means straight and and this really
means to like take the straight path or
to straighten things out it gets
translated as success or accomplishment
so we feel you know better when we're
being successful when things are going
the way that we want them to you know
for example we're not being frustrated
by our technology turning against us you
know when you are trying to get a task
done and suddenly Microsoft or Zoom or
pick whatever software you want Chrome
wants to update you know you can get it
kind of ticked off right because it's
interfering with you being successful
but if you are successful then you tend
to be a bit more sanguine a little bit
more happy go lucky about things
likewise in the next one and pleros say
this means in abundance having a lot of
stuff so when you've got plenty of money
in the bank when you've got lots of food
stored up I know for myself when I have
ironed all of my dress shirts which is a
task I don't like doing but um you know
has to be done because nobody else is
going to hire them for me and I I do a
good job at it since I've been doing it
since a you know I was a kid
um when I do that and I can look at them
all lined up I'm like oh I'm rich now
I'm not really rich but it feels kind of
like that when you put away your your
clothes folded up or however you do them
in abundance right when we don't feel
again like we have to compete with other
people people or we're operating in
scarcity we feel pretty good and then
we're not going to get angry as easily
the next three that he he sums things up
with are kind of interesting so n alupia
a Lupe is pain a Lupia is a freedom from
pain so
you wake up are you achy are you not
right did you get a good night's sleep
are you still kind of sleep deprived do
you have a sinus infection that's
bothering you your nose is burning
you're coughing a bit or are you feeling
pretty good so in Freedom From Pain we
tend not to get angry we tend to be
calmer and this is a very interesting
one and Hayden May who bristique right
and that actually follows in the passage
right on the Olympia and you know
there's an and or chi in Greek so
pleasure so he's talking about lack of
pain and now there's pleasure and the
pleasure is not hublistike not involving
insult not involving putting somebody
else down innocent pleasure we could say
and all of these could be examples of
innocent pleasure a lot like that and
then the last one an LP day epi-a-k now
epide is coming from alpis Hope and
that's a an emotion that's a positive
one right
um epi-a-k it gets translated sometimes
as virtuous so in virtuous hope it's
probably better to translate it as
befitting or appropriate hope you know
hoping for the sorts of things that you
it makes sense for you to hope for
you're not going too far with it you're
not hoping for things that are
detrimental to yourself or to other
people like oh man I hope I get totally
drunk at the party puke all over myself
damage somebody else's property no no
it's not that that kind of Hope right
instead it's uh the kinds of hopes or
expectations about the future that are
befitting that are good and so all of
these conditions Aristotle says are
examples of ways in which people can
keep from getting angry if we put people
in these situations rather than in
situations that are their opposites
um you know for example and Plato say in
abundance let's take stuff away from
people we're going to tend to make them
more Angry as opposed to calm or mild so
all of these are very important factors
some of them can turn you know if the
play becomes too serious if the laughter
is is you know directed at somebody else
and making fun of them if we're at a
festival or holiday and it turns out to
be a massive hassle if our uh
appropriate hopes are disappointed we
could get angry but in general these are
going to keep a person the opposite of
angry calm or mild